I live in New York and I love living in
New York but doing comedy in New York
has its ups and downs like last year I
want a local comedy competition and for
winning they gave me a giant trophy and
I then got to take that giant trophy and
hold it while I rode the subway home for
an hour holding a giant trophy while you
ride public transportation for an hour
is a great way to let people know you
won but you're still losing one thing I
actually like about the subway though is
I like all the artists down on the
platform doing creative things for money
like one time I walked past a man who
was sitting behind a sign that said pick
a price pick a subject get a poem and
have time to interact with him then but
I do have a plan for next time I see him
I want to go up and be like hey let me
get a $2.00 poem about pigeons just cuz
that's a fun random thing to request and
then regardless of the first poem he
gives me I want to follow that up with
now let me get a five-dollar poem about
pigeons just because I want to see how
prolific this man can be and when you
think about it that's a 150 percent
price increase from one poem of the next
and I expect to see that reflected in
his work those two dollar metaphors
better turn to five dollar allegories
that's all I'm saying just want to keep
him on his toes go be like let me get a
one dollar poem about God now let me get
a 10 dollar poem about string cheese
it's been a big week for me earlier in
the week I got a new beard trimmer and
that's exciting because that means that
my old beard trimmer is now my new ball
hair trimmer
and my old ball hair trimmer is now my
friend Kyle's new beard trimmer what's
up Kyle and then a month ago my
girlfriend and I moved in together it
was a big step in doing so we had to
take the prerequisite couple shopping
trip to Ikea go and get everything for
our place we're putting everything
together had IKEA parts all over our
floor one of my friends came over sorry
everything on the floor he asked us what
we were building my girlfriend said our
lives together at literally the exact
same time as I said shelves so then I
started building the couch I've been
sleeping on we tried to keep the romance
alive so we have date night once a week
last date I took her to was to one of
those wine and paint places where you
can bring your own bottle of wine and
sip it while the instructor teaches the
whole class how to paint the entire
class was full of couples where the
women were very excited to be there
and the men were very clearly dragged
there but after about an hour of
drinking wine the women completely
stopped caring about the painting and
the men got super serious about the paid
like all the women we're just going
behind their boyfriends like whoo
we're all like [ __ ] I'm trying to
contour you think Impressionism just
happens I'm in to try new things though
which is why at the beginning of summer
I tried acid for the first time yeah and
I had always heard acid was a good drug
to do outdoors in nature I live in New
York not a lot of options so I ate the
acid and I went to Central Park
I found the big lake in the middle of
Central Park and I found a nice little
rock by the side of the lake and I was
just sitting there minding my business
watching the Ducks float on the water
about ten minutes go by
turn to my right and there's a young
little girl sitting next to me on the
rock and she looks up at me and she goes
hey mister you want to hear a riddle and
I was like absolutely I've never want to
hear a riddle so badly before in my life
but you got a kid and she goes what's
the beginning and the end of time and
the beginning and end of everywhere and
I was like like does she know I'm on
acid right now you know I mean like I'm
expecting her to say something like how
much wood would a woodchuck chuck if a
woodchuck could chuck wood she's coming
at me about space and time I wasn't
ready for it so I asked repeated she
said what's the beginning of end the end
of time beginning and end of everywhere
you guys know the answer the letter e
something she wrote on the back but
Laffy Taffy wrapper almost altered my
existence
you guys were great
you